tigers today send spencer turnbull to
the mound his second start of the year
first start was
quite impressive in five innings of work
against pittsburgh here is carlos
santana
outfield just about straight up grossman
left but doing center reyes and wright
3-2 swinging a miss you got him with a
riding fastball up and away
boy at 94 also oh i mean that ball just
exploded up there
now salvador perez playing his 1 000th
game as a royal
salvi what a career 2015 world series
mvp six-time all-star five gold gloves
he swings and knocks one to right back
goes victor ray is still going back and
that ball's off the wall
and salvi will cruise into second base
with a two-out double
you had to know he'd make an impact on a
special day game one thousand
now jorge solaris had some success
against turnbull and his career steps to
the plate
solaire wedding the two two swinging a
fly ball
center field not deep akil badu will
drift in make the easy grab
for out number three double does no harm
perez stranded at second
tigers bad in the bottom of the first
inning scoreless with the royals
brad keller gets the start for kansas
city
terrible year so far tough in his career
against the tigers two outs and that
leaves it up
to willie castro willie has only
two hits in the series but one of them
he took a very good pitch from brady
singer
down and in a slider engulfed it out of
the ballpark
two on two out nothing nothing score
we're in the first inning
the royals in detroit kc has won the
first three games of this series
here's the pitch a swing and a fly ball
to left field ben and tendy back
and he is there for the catch and brad
keller
survives a wobbly first inning he denies
the tigers
and we head to the second inning of play
the royals nothing the tigers nothing
and the batter will be andrew benintendi
slow roller cut off by willy castro in a
nice play
one two three second inning we go to the
bottom of the second scoreless in
detroit
royals and tigers scoreless as we head
to the bottom of the second inning of
play
keller to face akil badu the 2-2 pitch
is
swung on and miss struck him out first
strikeout
for keller and now the number nine
hitter victor reyes
facing his good buddy brad keller that
ball
hit sharply and it is caught by whit
merrifield
on the line towards right field so
victor reyes lines out
the tigers are done in the second inning
they leave a man at second base
we head to the third at comerica the
royals nothing and the tigers nothing
although santana just won for 11 in the
series
swing and a ball well struck down the
right field line way back and that ball
is gone
a two-run homer carlos santana
and the royals take a two-nothing lead
in detroit
he tattooed that baseball his fifth
homer on the season
rbis 17 and 18.
miguel cabrera very dependable in these
situations runner at third less than two
down
one-on-one on miguel cabrera in field
back the 1-1
ground ball up the middle diving attempt
but under the glove of lopez
grossman scores miguel cabrera has an
rbi and the tigers are on the board now
trailing
two to one so runners at the corners one
out
willie castro switch hitter batting
left-handed he's their second baseman
today
brad from the stretch now delivers
and a swing and a little squibber too
short they'll go home with a throw
and lopez throws out miguel cabrera for
the second out of the inning a little
broken bat little
roller to short and lopez goes home
immediately to salvador perez for the
put out there
and now they're going to check on
salvador pres nick kenny and
mike matheny are out there nick kenny
is talking with him and salby wants to
throw the baseball
to hunter dozier first and second two
down the battle will be
rookie rule five draft d left-handed
hitting akil badu who struck out
swinging
his first time and the one two and a
swing and a miss and a good
slider down and keller has a second
strikeout of the ball game
a rocky inning but the tigers settle for
one we go to the fourth the royal still
in front it's now two one royals here's
benetti he grounded to
second his first time runner at second
here's the one two
swung on and missed good block grinder
with a good block and throws him out at
first base
once again spencer turnbull strains a
runner in scoring position
second strikeout of the day ends the
fourth the tigers bad in the bottom of
the fourth inning trailing 2-1
here in detroit grinder at the plate he
swings and hits a soft pop-up into
shallow center
dyson in dice won't get it nico goodram
will score grinder will turn
and hold a little pop fly and if jerrod
dyson
can't get it you've hit it in the right
spot
a little bloop and the tigers have tied
the game at two
good merryfield at the plate again
batting with the runner at third in less
than two outs
it has always been tough against detroit
346 career hitter
against the tigers turnbull's pitch
a swing and a shot to left field this
will be deep enough backing up the left
fielder making the catch
is robbie grossman and tagging at third
coming home
is gerard dyson terrific job by
whitmerfield
his sacrifice fly gives the royals a 3-2
lead and now akail badu steps to the
plate
keller bends at the waist comes set the
3-0 pitch
swung on they let him swing he lifts it
in the air left center field
dyson under it makes the catch so yes
keller
does go five gives up two runs that
likely will be it for
the big right-hander but we head to the
sixth end of the play
another batter will be ryan o'hearn who
has
popped out foul and singled today the
wind up in the one-two
slider a little bit low check swing did
he go yes he did appeal down to third
chris conroy rings him up if that's the
end of the day that's a strong finish
for spencer turnbull his fifth strikeout
ends the sixth
it has been a grinding five innings for
brad keller and now he'll be pitching to
cam gallagher and we assume that
that has something to do with salvi's
right thumb and keller white had 100
pitches now and he's two-thirds of the
way through the sixth inning so now
he'll get
the number nine hitter victor reyes he
was lined to second grounded into a
double play and
keller's one out away from a quality
start
six innings and hopefully two runs
stroke to center dyson goes back and
he's there
falling backward dicey got turned around
a little bit in that deep center field
detroit though but he made the play
gerard dyson comes through
tumbles to the ground as he pulls down
out number 18
for brad keller i think now we can say
his day is probably done but
turns out to be a very productive day we
go to the seventh the royals lead is
three to two
it was just announced it salvi indeed
left the game because of his right thumb
right
thumb discomfort so two on
two out and willie castro stands in
switch hitting second baseman who
reached out in infield hit his last time
up one out of three today
324 career hitter against the royals
wow how about this job what a turnaround
in the inning
speaking of carlos santana the 1-1
ground ball the first diving backhanded
stop by castro couldn't get the ball out
of his glove as he looked his second
but he makes the play at first that's a
great play by harold castro on a ball
that
looked like he was headed into right
field and that would have put runners at
the corners with nobody out that was a
frozen rope that's a quick glove right
there there's no question about it cam
gallagher at the plate the strike ones
swinging a soft ground ball on one hop
to first scooped up by
cabrera that bat chipped scooped up by
castro makes a play unassisted
for the third out here in the eighth
inning tigers bad in the bottom of the
eight they trail 3-2
victor reyes at the plate here's the
one-two pitch
swung on and missed struck him out and
the ball in the dirt cam gets up tags
the base runner
and greg holland does it again how he
got out of the jam
what a wizard paging mr houdini
mr harry houdini runner at third base
nobody out and greg holland with a
masterful performance
the royals head to the ninth inning
leading three to two
hanzer alberta will come on to pinch it
for gerard dyson
soto sets again the 3-2 swinging a
pop-up
into shallow right a couple of steps out
of the outfield grass
castro makes the catch soto strands two
last shot for the tigers we got the
bottom of the ninth inning in detroit
it's 3-2 kansas city
and the battle will be candelario
stomach's first pitch
swung on hit in the air left side ben
and tendy coming on
coming on makes the catch and the royals
for the
first time in the franchise's history
sweep a four-game series in detroit